hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report even just rummaging around the
studio here you find all kinds of
interesting things this is a toy that
was popular while ago to teach kids how
to hijack airplanes
says Cubana on it kind of fun and then
here we have a Russian nesting doll
matroyshka petrushka a petrushka mutt
roast
pierogi the borscht and here you have
Putin and Trump you know it's all about
date aunt and getting along and with our
greatest ally and friend Russia here is
you know plate good for the kids and you
know you open her up and there's other
things in here so while we proceed here
in the first half I'll just see what
what come what comes because you clearly
cannot speak Russian even though you are
Russian double agent you must also call
it nesting dollars that everything I
know about Russia I learned from
watching boris and Natasha on the
Bullwinkle show that's the same with
most of our commentators our Russian
experts on the new linkle and rocky
squirrel you know not many squirrels
make it to cartoon stardom but there is
rocky the squirrel the flying squirrel
and Bullwinkle the moose great show this
is how our Russia experts learn all
their information about Russia and the
United States yeah but I want to turn to
this headline about education I'm
talking about our experts on the news
here you know they learn from cartoons
but in fact perhaps that's the best way
to learn because the knowledge economy
is a myth we don't need more
universities to feed it governments
around the world believe that to remain
competitive in a global economy they
must become smarter in an attempt to
boost its knowledge intensive nasai
government has just launched a plan to
overhaul the university sector it aims
to transform universities by creating
many more of them the hope is that this
will increase the number of people with
degrees and the UK will be a more
competitive economy that's it Geoff yeah
that's his clear joke because there's
only Cambridge and Oxford and those are
the only two universities where you can
go to and then get a job that pays more
than minimum wage or you're working for
delivery so this is just virtue
signaling by the people in the
bureaucracy trying to make pretend that
there is some kind of egalitarianism in
the UK that allows for advancement of
people willing to work hard that's false
it's a rigid class
it's almost as bad as the Indian
Untouchables when living up in the caste
system if you're a toothless Mancunian
you're not gonna end up working for the
BBC that's never gonna happen so let's
see what's under this one okay they dial
underneath here oh this is Clinton and
Yeltsin okay this was a very famous
period in the collapse of the Soviet
Union when America rigged that election
to put their man in Yeltsin who then
gave away the country to freakin
oligarchs which pretty much destroyed
everything for a while before our Putin
came along I know that you were educated
at NYU and our university system here
and I could say that I'm sure pretty
sure that after that one you will not
know who any other presidents I'm a bit
frightened now because the next time
going digging deeper through history is
when you know nobody really cared about
the Soviet Union really at all because
you know we were all much more innocent
in those days obviously in the United
Kingdom they want to expand the
university system they want to offer
more degrees of course in in the United
Kingdom actually even though they just
started to introduce university tuition
fees versus the u.s. where we've had
them for decades they actually graduate
in the United Kingdom with even more
debt than Americans - but we do have the
American system to look at and they fact
they found that the majority of jobs
being created today do not require
degree level of qualifications in the US
and 2010 20% of jobs required a
bachelor's degree 43 percent required a
high school education and 26 percent did
not even require a high school degree
meanwhile 40 percent of young people
study for degrees this means over half
of the people gaining degrees today will
find themselves working in jobs that
don't require a degree you know a degree
to work at your portal and get into
projectile-vomiting anybody who works
there smart enough not to eat the food
Wow I got that all mixed up that's
amazing but also you see what happens in
the United States is and as they point
out is that those who just get a college
a high school degree I see you're really
afraid you definitely are before brave
enough Brezhnev and
was the America next Nixon afford Nixon
or Ford and then how about Khrushchev
and Kennedy
the answer is Gorbachev
so they went backwards of for is there's
no time line there's no accurate time
line here and Reagan say America we
don't keep and figure out what that gave
ready Gorbachev and oh that's our Ronald
Reagan Gorbachev and Reagan this was day
time you know oh yeah you know he's the
only man in America that actually knows
anything about Russia and he says this
is to be emulated that Trump is
emulating the Reagan Gorbachev day taunt
era where they met for hours on end in
closed-door sessions to talk about
denuclearization in a very pressing
political agenda we didn't have 24-hour
news cycle at that time and we did have
the equivalent of Russia gate but it was
the Republic in the right wing that was
pushing that and they were saying that
Reagan was Russia's dupe and there his
like their puppet and so yeah so now the
next headline killing me I bet you it
will be Kennedy and Khrushchev that's my
instinct but I could be anyway so so in
the United States are saying that
low-skilled jobs are now being taken
more and more by people with university
degrees thus pushing out the the bottom
rung of that but it's also this is the
scariest thing this section I'm about to
read to you now it is uncertain whether
universities are even delivering on
their core purpose one recent study
tracked thousands of students during
their time at university it uncovered a
rather disturbing picture after two
years at university forty-five percent
of the students showed no significant
improvement in their cognitive skills
after four years 36 percent of students
had not improved in their ability to
think and analyze problems in some
courses such as Business Administration
students cognitive abilities actually
declined in the first few years so your
cognitive ability declines in the first
few years as a
this administration student somebody
like Donald Trump he studied business at
University of Pennsylvania so these are
the people that are running our economy
by the way if you go to business school
and apparently you actually become
dumber when you go there well there's a
reason for that because Wall Street
hiring people with no empathy if you
have a well-rounded liberal education
you would by definition improve your
empathy toward other people's other
cultures ideas you'd have be able to
think cognitively if you will want to
use that term about a multiplicity of
ideas but Wall Street wants people that
are without empathy they want people
that are on the spectrum the autism
spectrum in suffering severe autism
because they want them to look coldly at
the numbers into harvest gains like you
would harvest organs out of kidney
you know from homeless people I mean
that's what they want so it makes sense
that cognitive abilities are on the wane
because the economy is becoming
financialized and that's who's being
paid in this economy the people at the
top not being paid to think you're being
paint or steel you know you mentioned
the caste system in India they do have
the Brahmin class and they're not
expected to work they're just expected
to think you're expected to just be a
scholar and think about things we used
to have that back in ancient Greece and
stuff you had philosophy he says he's
working somewhere in the City of London
but actually I've never actually seen
him not in the Cambridge that's just
because he's Western eyes he has to
pretend to be a working but le so what's
that thing I don't know barrages yeah
the fact is that we used to have
thinkers and philosophers we no longer
value that and therefore it in fact
you're the highest value in the US
economy is to go to business school and
apparently that you're being a you know
you profit from thinking less so that's
actually proven here but this is a
system as you said financialized and
it's all really a debt racket and they
they they you know cloak it with these
highfalutin words like we're just trying
to educate the population
it's a knowledge economy we're all just
going to be smart and wealth will drone
operators you know in nevada some are
bombing children in yeah
you know that you don't want empathy
okay so who's in the we gotta open up
now open it up go ahead it's okay
it's that looks like I think that's I
think that's Khrushchev is that
Khrushchev that's that's that's that's a
bad rap that I think that's actually
Jimmy Carter right and Brezhnev ah Jimmy
Carter and you are um yes brush Nev
Jimmy Carr in there and Brezhnev so what
happened during the Brezhnev Carter era
think Cold War was pretty hot at that
time the Cold War was hot and that was
the days when the Olympics used to be
great
now it's the opposite Cold War 2.0 the
Olympics it's all like you know it's not
like oh boycott and stuff like that
back then we used to be like it was like
professional wrestling or our
professional wrestling which isn't
really professional it's just fake it's
all entertainment hole we used to be
like yeah down with the bed during this
period you had the famous hockey summit
Canada versus Russia during this era you
would know better than I this was when
the Philadelphia Flyers started beating
up Russians on I want to ask Putin when
I interview him later this year about
that series you hope I'm gonna be
interviewing Putin about hockey date on
ice hockey date on later this year again
I'm gonna quickly move to this final
headline because you know an education
might not be necessary it is certainly
not necessary really for a soldier more
than tariffs China sees trade war as a
new u.s. containment tactic it's about
time a force much of what the US has
actually done over the past two decades
I would say since 2000 since 2001 the
the invasion of Iraq the Russia gate
stuff is actually all I believe about
containment of China and now China sees
us they don't see the trade war is
actually being about the trade war that
it's about containment of China they
don't want China to grow any more and
this this opinion piece over in Asia and
a Hong Kong newspaper is saying that
basically they're both under estimating
each other and their willingness to
resort to military means America China
America China that they both could
start hot water greatest ally America in
case to go to our China Russia that's
the point of this new doll mature mature
skin doll exercise you see Americans
always been you know and some degrees a
lie you know buddy's like frenemies I
say American Russia of frenemies
we're frenemies right but let's because
we only have 40 seconds left I'd like to
see who is in the final bit I'm assuming
it's Kennedy and Khrushchev see as it
gets smaller the the representations of
these presidents really get worse
this is the last one freaking hard to
see it's yes Kennedy and I guess that's
Christian it's not a good likeness of
yeah it's not a good likeness so that
was it actually looks like Gorbachev but
I think they the Chinese people who made
this got their orders wrong and they put
Gorbachev and Kennedy put him twice
here's my Khrushchev impression remember
that a Cold War they are the Bay of Pigs
Oh Cuba it all comes back to Cuba and
the Cuban Bay of Pigs see that's the
kind of poetry you don't see on
mainstream media they only see it here
in the cons report why because we're in
love well we got to go to the second
half don't go away
much more coming your way
welcome back to the constant report I'm
Max Keiser welcome to the show the one
and only the crypto genius
Sinclair welcome oh thanks max the only
go you know your first name now like
Madonna
you're just Sinclair ma'am look I'm with
whatever you call about Claire Skinner
of bit Mari he's also at the black
blockchains summit the black bloc change
summit is coming up look we're trying to
take this amazing technology and solve
some long existing problems in the black
communities and we think this is a great
way to do it so we're gonna have subject
matter experts in some of these
particular topics be it education
dealing with energy as well as having
folks who are well versed in blockchain
technology we're gonna put them together
discuss these issues try to come up with
some you know actions you know that we
can take from there and then we're gonna
have a hackathon from that point until
November and then we're gonna take all
that energy from the hackathons and
hopefully next year we would have done
something better and then we're not
gonna just have a meeting after a
meeting to meet we're gonna actually do
like they did with the Declaration of
Independence they went out and start
shooting folks so after we do our
meeting what you're gonna go out shoot
people independence a huge deal not
because of the meeting but because of
what they did after they declared
independence they went out there and
started getting it like shooting a film
well not like actually shooting people
with guns so we're not gonna shoot
anybody were going to use technology we
think that's better than politics with
things better than protesting with even
things better than philantropy okay they
focus on this particular so the black
struggle in America you think a near
position is that technology is another
rail that offers emancipation it not to
be too you know find a point on it is
that a fair statement absolutely it
could be an underground railroad or just
another rail absolutely it's in dire
need
you know racism let me tell me if I'm
wrong racism is as
prevalent in American society today as
it's ever been
right it's systemic it is actually
something as a part of the fabric and we
need to do something to change it I
think technology waiting for someone to
come save us is not gonna work so
determination Jim Crow is gone but the
prison industrial complex is amazing is
here and is our generation who's
actually felt the most like coming of
age in the 80s you'd think about it you
know prior to that it was a lot of
prison population but we got hit with
all these other things and next thing
you know we're in a even worse situation
so I think it's it's time for us to use
technology no waiting for you know the
cult of personality of people that we
love is in political office like Obama
or our people that people hate like a
Trump that's not a political strategy we
need to use technology and not get
caught up in these distractions I'm not
saying politics is a distraction but
anyway okay so Satoshi is black that's
t-shirt yes and so talk up a little bit
about that you talk about Maximus your
idea so I would even be at this point
you want to ask me that question what is
this about what is Satoshi is black
about max well I'm telling you what I
think it's about I think it's about you
know liberation and the fact that this
technology of blockchain and Bitcoin is
is offering a way forward from our
constrictions in our restrictions and in
our chains in a lot of ways you know
racism hurts everybody and that's just
the victims of racism that are outright
victims but it hurts everybody and this
country has either been you know built
on a cemetery of indigenous population
and then made whole made possible
through slavery you know that was the
economic innovation of previous
centuries was slavery that was the
blockchain they were on the chain gang
there was a frickin chain of people you
know that's how America got wealthy
right so now we know we're all black in
that sense when they bring in censorship
now and when they bring in wholesale
kind of sensory a central shape on the
internet that that's
intolerable we're back we're all
fighting the same fight now yeah I think
you're I think it was a Monty Grenier
she talked about when you look at
victims of racism as Canaries and they
in a was it : and the coal mine so
because of this racial environment it's
not the canary is at fault but their
respiratory system is more Sisseton
because of the things going on but that
gas to kill everybody so I think what
you just said does directly relates to
the fact that many of these things we've
seen from drugs being put in communities
and the military industrial complex it
may start off with one population but as
let me ask you this question you know
everyone's familiar with the crack head
and the nod or get nod in the hood and
there's a degenerate look at that man
he's on he's on heroin okay now in the
white community they say oh we have an
opiate crisis no my brother is a couple
years older to me
he's been on drugs for Moses adult life
and he's talked about how the prison's
change he said when he first got in late
80s yeah it was very punitive he said
now they got so many little programs for
folks to kind of like feel good about
themselves and kind of like how come
white people have an opiate crisis and
their micro dosing right foot black
people are strung out on Iran and their
crack is animals done what so that's the
same again there's a way you practice on
one population now it leads to the other
property even if we're talking about
slavery you know it's hard to compete
for fair wages
we need to got one population that can
be owned by one and yet you're over here
trying to figure out how do I get rid of
the pharmaceutical companies are
responsible to do peak crisis they ran
out of people in the get out of mess up
you know they had to go jump over to the
white population to make money cuz they
already messed up the black population
pretty bad so they got to jump over to
the white population that's why raw in
the hood we're all black essentially
Satoshi is black now talk about
technology let's talk about this so the
technology at it's there's there's two
schools of thought
one is we heard safe teen talk about his
book that the Bitcoin standard
and it's a very Western approach to
money hard money and why bitcoin is a
better source of money but in when I
talk to you you know you come to it from
a slightly different angle of there's a
spiritual element to this that goes back
way back way back before America way
before Western cultures it goes back
thousands of years you know maybe even
half a million years that there's
something more critical at stake here
there's an essence here there's a
spiritual quality to it can you speak on
that yeah I think what we've seen a lot
of these economists even in the
blockchain space their context of what
civilization starts in a very late stage
and even when you're here
Elon must talk about first principles
we're looking at the conditions in the
world to start just 100 years ago or 200
years ago in America or even 500 years
ago thus we're still very recent I mean
we've been civilized people for
thousands of years and what existed
before that you know European a
so-called Western culture is very late
it's very young so there's been cultures
in Africa we still can't build pyramids
so even when people talk about technical
innovation we still can't build a
pyramid and have them in Mexico and they
have a mattress so if a blockchain a
Bitcoin is the perfect money we all say
it is and if it disenfranchises central
banks and banks and it puts fiat money
out of business and it takes us back as
a culture as a civilization to one
before we had that Western notion of
money Oh
aren't we always going back to our
African roots essentially like Bitcoin
could take us back to Africa all of us
the entire species of humanity of humans
back to something that is primordial 19
prime or something is more humane more
human and that whole humanity comes out
of a spiritual space it's not the other
way around and I think that spiritual
space allows us to exchange value in a
way that's more than just transactional
there's something else there's the
energy there's there's something more to
it you see many of these analysis they
leave that energy out as if these all
are just a series of transactions
there's more to how we got where we are
now than just saying that we're
translate because okay listen to safe
teen and he talks about economic
starting with scarcity
but when we talked to you and others who
take it back spiritually thousands and
thousands of years actually the
economics was defined by abundance
absolutely abundance so again people
even talk about the people of the Sun
ice people but at the end of the day if
you look at many parts of the world
people didn't have to worry about winter
coming and running around being afraid
that somehow something was going to be
there if you look at Europe and some of
these other cultures there was a real
sense of scarcity there made people
maybe even more confrontational if we
look at many parts of the world where
people are because they left the
motherland right I mean they spoke they
left Africa which was abundant to go
search for something else outside of the
Garden of Eden not only did they lose
their color but they started thinking
about everything in terms of scarcity
and they were already living in the
Garden of Eden right so Satoshi is
black.here here if he's successful we'll
go back to Eden which is freaking Africa
thank you and I think if we all start
changing that mindset we can create that
space no matter where we are and I think
that's what becomes very amazing about
the the global power of this technology
it doesn't have a jurisdiction we all
can start creating community beyond
these artificial fake borders that never
were very helpfully anyway and if you
think about it we start talking about
you know decentralization in Africa you
know they still over 2,000 languages
Africa was already decentralized it was
was until the colonizer came and carved
up spaces that had nothing to do with
actually creating a better space but it
was actually done to subdue people so I
think we can get to that space now not
just with the internet but actually with
this next layer with transactions and
being an exchange value in a very
powerful way through the black lightning
Network you know again we're laying
second layer second layer we're doing
lightning right now we did it Laurie yes
we did our first remittance transaction
from a node in Nigeria to a node in his
M Bob way back in March
so tell people what that mari is so--but
mari is a pan-african blockchain wallet
we hold Bitcoin Bitcoin in cash and
we're going to be coming up some
additional services and one of the big
things that we've been doing is our
allowed
but a cash out of crypto in Zimbabwe we
have a bank partner called Agri bank
that we've been working with that allows
people to cash out and we're now
expanded to other African countries one
of the big things is dealing with
regulators you know one area might not
be as warm as the other but if we have
an expansive offering we can be in
multiple African countries in our target
is trying to decolonize at the end of
the day you know Barclays and a lot of
these banks made their money off
exploiting us we don't need them anymore
we actually can exchange value
peer-to-peer and use this amazing
technology well we know the blockchain
technology and the peer-to-peer
applications are exploding in Africa
much probably is the most adoptive place
in the world is it probably because
there's just already a natural tendency
to think in this way yeah I think the
natural tendency the problem with most
of these developing countries though
it's not the local people most of these
African countries as well as Latin
America are still you know neo-colonial
states where they still look to the West
for approval so if you're a banker in
Africa and you're trying to do business
in Europe
you're still gonna unfortunately be
manipulated by the Swift bank or the
other systems that are out there so I
think this is a great opportunity to use
technology to change it okay so it's
black blockchain summit till May 10th
and 11th well Howard University historic
Howard University historically black
college amazing place in DC I'm speaking
hey Thank You max for speaking yeah and
thank you for us to tell she is black
fair enough thanks for being on the
class report yeah power I got a side off
oh sorry Sinclair okay calm down
let me get down let me get through with
this this thing hey we got to go and
that's gonna do it for this edition of
the Kaiser report with me max guys
aren't Stacy I would want to thank our
guests Sinclair Skinner oh bit Mari if
you under who I catch us on Twitter it's
guys the report until next time bye
y'all
[Music]